jolene jolene jolene
jolene uh dolly parton
yeah what do you think she did have a
humongous
bust for the for the size of her
shoulders
[Music]
let's start maybe a pretty easy one on
the list
um now of course everybody has to remain
uh a vigilant and go back to work but
remember
don't go back to work stay
in work but of course also remember
don't
go back to work
that would be our prime minister mr
boris johnson
[Laughter]
i'm gonna see some oh look
this is some this is this is what drama
school students
spend quite a lot of their day doing
mom is really wonderfully committed
to impersonating i would say a
tyrannosaurus rex
luther from umbrella academy
jolene jolene jolene
jolene dolly parton
yeah what do you think she did have a
humongous
bust for the for the size of her
shoulders she's got a
glorious big breast and a glorious big
songwriting brain okay listen to me we
have to get out of here
now we have to get to the chopper do you
know where the chopper is i can't
remember where i left it
[Laughter]
that was good that was none other than
mr ali schwarzenegger
bill dance entrepreneurship
help me donkey i've got a stone stuck in
my kind of tunnel here
trick that's the one
yeah baby austin powers
well i'm sorry i'm sorry that bug up
your ass had to die
[Laughter]
do you know what i'm gonna veer wildly
off the list now right and go
tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow
creeps in this petty pace from day
to day till the last syllable of
recorded time
is but a walking shadow a poor player
that struts
and threats his hour upon the stage and
is heard no more it is a tale
told by an idiot full of sound
and fury signifying
nothing hamlet
no which one is it macbeth macbeth i
know he's one of two
right so you get your fish season salt
pepper delicious marvelous no no
you [ __ ] idiot it's supposed to be
[ __ ] blue
oh it's interesting because it went in
my head it was jamie oliver and then it
became gordon ramsay
oh it's gorgeous what about this one
of course everybody said to me it was a
terrible idea
to do the voice like a 1980s game show
or
is uh bane
you